Das Bett neu überziehen gurkt mich schon bei meinem eigenen an.
Aber stell dir vor, du machst das über 100 Mal und das jeden Tag.
Autsch!
Hierher kommen junge Leute aus der ganzen Welt um die beste Zeit ihres Lebens zu haben.
Aber für diesen Spass krampfen viele Leute hinter den Kulissen.
Diese Woche hast du bestimmt jeden Tag 11 bis 12 Stunden gearbeitet.
Ja.
Drehen, drehen, drehen.
Diese Leute kommen nicht wegen unserer schönen Landschaft in die Schweiz,
sondern weil es manchmal einfach nicht anders geht.
Ich habe zwei Töchter und kam irgendwann an einem Punkt an dem ich ihnen nichts mehr zu essen geben konnte.
Es war wirklich schlimm.
Mona Vetsch -
drei Tage im Backpacker-Hostel.
Auf nichts vorbereitet,
aber auf alles gefasst.
Das ist "Mona mittendrin".
Ich bin völlig überfordert.
Rosalie ist mein Chef.
Es ist wie ein Labyrinth.
- Ja, irgendwie. Das ist ja ...
Es ist ein Labyrinth.
(Es geht von null auf 100.)
(Rosalie
ist die Leiterin des Hausdienstes.)
(Ursprünglich kommt sie aus Italien,
und auch ihre Putzcrew
ist international.)
Hallo miteinander.
Cristina aus Sri Lanka
und Dorje aus Tibet.
Ich bin Cristina.
- Mona. Freut mich.
Ich habe schon welche.
Hi, I'm Dorje.
- Dorje?
Ja. - Aus Tibet.
- Ich bin Mona.
Tibet, Sri Lanka und ...
- Andrea aus Spanien.
Super. Mona aus der Schweiz.
(Rosalie erklärt mir,
was beim Zimmermachen wichtig ist.)
Zuerst die Fenster öffnen.
Dann den Abfall wegräumen.
Kontrollieren, ob die Gäste
etwas im Zimmer vergessen haben.
Schau mal, Rosalie,
ich habe das hier erhalten.
Für die Bettwanzenfalle.
- Genau.
Wohin kommt das jetzt?
Unter das Bett.
- Okay.
Ohne Datum.
Siehst du? Da ist schon eine.
- Ah, dort ist sie.
Dort ist die andere.
- Ja, eine reicht.
Hast du schon mal
Bettwanzen gefangen? - Nein.
Zum Glück nicht.
Zeig mir, was ich machen kann!
Ich muss rasch kontrollieren.
Hallo.
Sie liegt noch im Bett,
oh mein Gott!
Ist es okay, wenn wir im Zimmer
putzen, wenn sie noch im Bett liegt?
Das ist normal in einem Hostel.
Blue is for the mirror
and red is for the ...
Jetzt platzen wir
einfach in ihr Zimmer.
Sorry, sie filmen nur,
wie ich hier putze. - Kein Problem.
Woher kommt ihr?
- Aus England.
Warum seid ihr hierhergekommen?
Wir waren in Frankreich und dachten:
"Komm,
gehen wir doch in die Schweiz."
Es sah so schön aus.
Und es ist auch schön.
Was habt ihr
von der Schweiz erwartet?
What kind of expectations
did you have?
Einfach schöne Dinge.
Die haben wir auch gefunden.
Es ist wunderbar. Schade,
dass wir nicht mehr Zeit haben.
Wir bleiben nur zwei Tage.
You can also with the tent.
And not much time?
- Yes.
(Keine Zeit mehr zum Reden.)
(Zwischen 150 und 200 Betten
werden täglich frisch angezogen,
und die Duvet-Roulade
muss perfekt sein.)
Ah!
* Treibende Musik *
Ist es so richtig?
- Nein.
Das ist die Distanz,
die gleiche Distanz.
So. Ja, genau.
Was sieht du, was ich nicht sehe?
Ah, das ist schmaler.
(Rosalie
arbeitete früher in Luxushotels.)
(Vielleicht
nimmt sie es darum so genau.)
Ja, dreckig.
Oh ja,
das Duftwasser habe ich vergessen.
* Treibende Musik *
Und jetzt zum Schluss ...
Was fehlt noch?
Die Türfalle.
- Ja.
(Es ist eng im Hostel - und heiss.)
Arbeitest du schon lange hier?
- Ja.
Du gehörst schon fast zum Inventar.
Doch, du verstehst es gut.
Ist Hochdeutsch besser für dich?
Etwas Hochdeutsch verstehe ich.
Arbeitest du schon lang hier?
Warst du wieder in Tibet?
Darfst du nicht?
- Nein.
Hast du Kontakt zu deiner Familie?
Warum?
Wenn sie merken, dass deine Familie
Kontakt mit dir hat ...
Wie ist das für dich?
Wie ist es für dich,
hier zu arbeiten?
Es ist wie mein zweites Zuhause.
Ja, die Schweiz
ist meine zweite Heimat.
Hast du hier
eine zweite Familie gefunden?
Ja, genau. Meine zweite Familie
ist hier in der Schweiz.
Danke für deine Hilfe.
- It's my job.
(Für lange Gespräche
reicht es beim Putzen nicht.)
(Wie es wohl ist, wenn man wie Dorje
seine Familie seit 25 Jahren
nicht mehr gesehen hat?)
(In der Schweiz hat er jetzt
eine Frau und ein Kind.)
(Deshalb sagt er,
er sei irgendwie angekommen.)
Mona? - Ja?
- Pause.
Pause, danke.
(Ich bin froh, dass es Rosalie auch
mit der Mittagspause genau nimmt.)
Niente? - No.
- Que no?
Guten Appetit.
Wie geht's, Mona? Müde?
- Müde.
Schon jetzt.
Warte nur bis morgen.
Was machen wir morgen?
- Tent.
Zelt?
(Zelt?
Noch verstehe ich nicht,
was die vielsagenden Blicke
bedeuten sollen.)
Du hat ja auch
an anderen Orten gearbeitet.
Ist es sehr streng,
hier zu arbeiten, oder normal?
Für uns ist es normal.
Ich bin etwas müde,
aber das ist jeden Tag so.
Ja, jeden Tag.
Aber wir sind Frauen,
und ohne Frauen läuft nichts.
Du hast so recht.
Ohne solche Frauen wie ihr
auf jeden Fall.
Lebst du hier mit deinem Mann?
Nein, ich habe keinen Mann.
Okay.
Aber vielleicht
finde ich ihn jetzt im Fernsehen.
Gib mir einfach deine Telefonnummer,
falls sich jemand spontan meldet.
Und warum bist du
in die Schweiz gekommen?
Italien hat nichts mehr zu bieten.
Rom ist in der Krise,
nicht mal die Jungen finden Arbeit.
Kannst du dir vorstellen,
wie schwierig das mit 54 ist?
Es gibt eh nichts.
... my age, there you get nothing.
(Und ich finde am Schluss
meiner Pause genauer heraus,
wo ich hier gelandet bin.)
(Der Gründer des Hostels,
Erich Balmer,
kennt offenbar sehr viele Promis.)
(Er gilt als Backpacker-Pionier.)
(Das Balmers gibt es
schon seit den 70er-Jahren.)
(Jetzt haben seine Töchter
das Geschäft übernommen.)
* Treibende Bassklänge *
(Am Nachmittag bin ich
an der Rezeption eingeteilt.)
(Hier hat Susan das Sagen.)
Yeah? Alright. You're welcome.
Enjoy your stay!
Zuerst checken wir sie ein
und informieren sie über das Hostel.
Und dann darüber,
was man unternehmen kann.
Wenn sie an Aktivitäten
interessiert sind,
z.B. Paragliding oder Canyoning,
dann helfen wir bei der Buchung.
Und das musst alles auch du machen?
Ich muss nicht,
aber meist machen wir es.
Ist das der Grund, wieso so
viele Junge in diese Region kommen?
Viele, ja.
Wegen solcher Aktivitäten
oder um zu wandern -
Natur, Berge, der See.
Aber oft verknüpfen sie es
mit einer solchen Aktivität.
Sie kommen drei Tage hierher
für einen Adrenalinkick?
Genau. Genau.
- Fliegst du selber auch?
Ja, Gleitschirm. - Gleitschirm?
- Ja, genau. - Okay.
Hello! How are you?
- (Mann) Good.
Wie kann ich dir helfen?
- Ich möchte einchecken.
Evan?
- Genau. Das bin ich.
Warst du am See?
Ich komme gerade vom Canyoning.
- Nice. Which canyon did you do?
Es war grossartig -
das Beste, das ich je gemacht habe.
Es war besser, als ich dachte,
und ein grösserer Adrenalinkick
als erwartet. Grossartig.
Wenn es du noch nie gemacht hast,
würde ich es dir
unbedingt empfehlen.
Es ist gleich hier hinten.
It's like right over here.
Das ist dein Schlüssel.
Du kannst dir dein Bett aussuchen.
Hier geht es die Treppe hoch.
Thanks a lot.
- You're welcome. See ya.
(In unserem Rücken
ist Geschäftsinhaberin Carmen Balmer
an der Rezeption aufgetaucht.)
Susan, ist das Lost and Found?
That's mine.
- Ah, das ist deine.
Ich wollte sie soeben in unser ...
- Da ist Lost and Found?
Wir hatten auch Gäste, die sich
z.B. einen Knochen gebrochen haben.
Deshalb haben wir im Lost and Found
auch Bilder von Knochen,
die liegen gelassen worden sind.
Die bewahren wir natürlich auf.
"Institut für Radiologie" -
jemand hat hier
seine Röntgenaufnahmen vergessen.
Was die in ihrem Wahn
alles vergessen ...
Kidsmen.
Hello.
- Hello.
Oh!
It's okay.
- Are you sure?
Bist du immer gut gelaunt
und hast immer Geduld?
Ja ...
Das ist manchmal nicht so einfach.
Was ist für dich anstrengend,
was zehrt an dir?
Es sind oft die gleichen Fragen.
Wenn z.B. jemand kommt ...
Sie sind oft voller Freude
und aufgeregt. Dann fragen sie:
Und dann:
Next!
Da muss man die Contenance bewahren,
um nicht loszulachen.
Man muss schauspielern.
(Susan) Wir haben eine Liste
mit 200 dummen Fragen.
Nein?
Regelmässig hören wir:
"Ich rufe Petrus an. Warte kurz,
in 30 Sek. habe ich eine Antwort."
Wann hört es auf zu regnen?
* Ruhige Musik *
(Gegen Abend
sind die meisten eingecheckt
oder zurück
von ihren Outdoor-Abenteuern.)
(In der Gemeinschaftsküche
herrscht Hochbetrieb.)
Oh, nichts für ungut.
(Viele hier sind vermutlich
zum ersten Mal weg vom Hotel Mama.)
(Was ich hier beobachte,
sieht teils recht unbeholfen aus.)
(Aber wer selber kocht, spart Geld.)
* Ruhige Musik *
(Es ist 19.30 Uhr, und Rosalie
ist immer noch am Waschen.)
(Erst wenn alles erledigt ist,
hat auch sie Feierabend.)
* Ruhige Musik *
(Am nächsten Morgen
habe ich Frühschicht mit Isabella.)
(Vor 7 Uhr muss das Frühstücksbuffet
bereit sein.)
(Wer in unseren Hotels
ein solches Buffet anrichtet,
habe ich mir noch nie überlegt.)
(Es sind Menschen wie Isabella,
die ursprünglich aus Rom kommt.)
(Von Rom nach Matten -
das klingt nach einem Kulturschock.)
Wie ist es für dich,
hier zu arbeiten?
Ich liebe es.
Ich mache diesen Job ja schon lange.
Und wie ist es,
in der Schweiz zu arbeiten?
Oh, das war anfangs nicht einfach.
Das ist aber schon drei Jahre her,
und ich mag die Schweiz.
Aber der Anfang war hart.
Was war am schwierigsten?
For me?
Meine Familie zurückzulassen,
war schwierig.
Ich bin alleine hier,
das ist nicht einfach.
Because I'm alone here
and it's not easy.
Wie hast du denn
diese Entscheidung getroffen?
In welchem Moment wurde dir klar,
dass es nicht mehr geht,
dass du Rom und Italien
verlassen musst?
Ich hatte keine Wahl.
Ich habe zwei Töchter,
die ich irgendwann
nicht mehr ernähren konnte.
Das war schrecklich.
Ich musste mir einen Job suchen,
und so kam ich in die Schweiz.
Ohne jemanden zu kennen,
mit einem kleinen Koffer.
Like this, without knowing nobody.
And with a little suitcase.
Und jetzt habe ich es geschafft.
Darauf bin ich stolz.
Es war nicht einfach,
ganz alleine an einem fremden Ort
zu landen und zu wissen,
dass ich das jetzt durchziehen muss.
Ich glaube, der liebe Gott
hat mich hierhergebracht.
Es ist der richtige Ort.
Interlaken ist der Ort der Engel.
(Für Isabella ist das Balmers
die Rettung in der Not.)
(Für die Menschen,
die zum Frühstück kommen,
ist es eine Station von vielen.)
(Sie bleiben
durchschnittlich zwei Tage.)
(Eine Übernachtung
inklusive Frühstück
kostet, je nach Zimmer,
zwischen 30 und 80 Fr.)
* Ruhiger Popsong:
"Hymn For The Weekend" von Coldplay *
# You know
you make my world light up.
Guten Morgen, wie geht's?
Nicht gerade blendend.
Und was läuft mit deinem Pass?
Ich habe soeben nochmals angerufen,
aber sie haben ihn nicht gefunden.
Oh nein.
Jetzt muss ich einen neuen besorgen.
Und was machst du?
Ich muss
zur australischen Botschaft.
Ist diese in Bern?
- Nein, in Genf.
Also ist heute ein Kurztrip
nach Genf angesagt.
Genau.
Es kostet brutal viel.
- Es ist zu teuer für uns beide.
Du musst alleine gehen?
Ja, es ist so teuer.
It's like ... ehm ...
Ja, das kostet 150 Fr.
Ich drücke die Daumen.
(Dorje arbeitet auch schon.)
(Und vor dem Znüni treffe ich
den ultimativen Stammgast: Max.)
Willst du einen Kaffee?
Ja?
- Ja.
Willst du rein?
- Ja, rein.
Wie immer.
Ich möchte rein und dann ...
- Sicher.
Max' Eltern
gehörte das Gebäude hier.
Ist er hier drin aufgewachsen?
Er ist hier drin aufgewachsen.
Ja, genau.
(Max sei autistisch,
erzählt mir Geschäftsführer Jan.)
(Und er gehöre seit Jahren
fix zum Balmers.)
Dass er ein Teil der Dorf-
gemeinschaft und des Betriebs ist,
ist auch nicht selbstverständlich.
- Nein, gar nicht.
Es ist sehr familiär.
Max lebt schon so lange hier,
jeder kennt ihn.
Und es kümmern sich
auch alle um ihn,
wenn etwas passieren würde.
- Absolut.
Dann wissen alle ...
Ich setze mich kurz hier hin.
Nur weil er
ein paar Schwierigkeiten hat,
schieben wir ihn nicht
in ein Heim ab.
Wir versuchen, ihn zu integrieren,
er ist ein Teil von uns.
(Max) Ja, eben.
- Musst du weiter?
Schau mal!
(Im Balmers
hat Max auch eine eigene Aufgabe.)
Was ist da drin?
- Das ist eine Postkarte.
(Die Postkarten der Gäste.)
So läuft das bei uns.
Er schaut, wohin sie geschickt wird.
(Undeutlich) Nach Amerika.
Nach Amerika?
- Ja, ja.
Ja, ja, USA - stimmt.
Genau.
- Ja.
Das fasziniert ihn.
Max, wir haben heute
noch ein Paket für dich.
Für die Post.
- Ja.
* Ruhige Musik *
(Max geht
mit der Karte zur Post ...)
(... und bei den Backpackern
geht die Post ab.)
(Mit dem Quad oder dem Gleitschirm -
Hauptsache, es kickt.)
(Aber ich bin nicht
zum Vergnügen hier.)
(Ich fahre mit Dorje und Jan
zum Zeltdorf.)
(Das Tent Village
liegt am Rande von Matten.)
(Hier ist eine Übernachtung
noch günstiger als im Hostel.)
(Wer es einfach und
improvisiert mag, ist hier richtig.)
(Jetzt erfahre ich auch,
was die Frauen gestern Mittag
mit den Zelten meinten.)
Es riecht speziell hier drin.
Jetzt musst du dir vorstellen ...
Wie warm ist es draussen? 20 °C?
- Ja.
Wenn draussen 35 °C herrschen
oder wie heute Nachmittag 30 °C,
dann muss man hier drinnen
bei 40 °C die Betten machen.
Dann schwitzt man ziemlich.
Das Ganze läuft eigentlich so.
Das Zeug runter.
(Jan hat einen ordentlich Drive.)
(Dass der Geschäftsführer selbst
an der Basis anpackt
und die Betten anzieht,
scheint mir recht einzigartig.)
(Im Balmers kann es sich niemand
leisten, wählerisch zu sein.)
(Auch jene nicht,
die hier übernachten.)
(Mit fünf anderen Personen
in einem solchen Zelt zu schlafen,
ist mit 20-50 Fr. günstig
für die teure Schweiz.)
Good morning.
- Hast du schon Pläne für heute?
Vielleicht gehen wir wandern.
Aber heute ist der 4. Juli,
und ich bin Amerikaner.
Im Hostel steigt eine Party.
- Ja, ich komme sicher.
Und vielleicht
springen wir noch kurz in den See.
Bis später!
Also.
So.
(Jan muss weiter,
und ich helfe jetzt Dorje.)
(Wir sind schon fast
ein eingespieltes Team.)
Hast du in Tibet
in den Bergen gelebt?
Ja.
Weit oben?
Ganz oben bei Lhasa,
wo es viele Yaks hat.
Ah, bei den ...
Yak ... Horse ...
Habe ich zwei Tage frei,
gehe ich ins Oberland.
Hiking?
- Ja, ja.
Gehst du wandern oder klettern?
Nur wandern.
In den Bergen ist es wie in Tibet.
Das ist wie bei dir zu Hause.
- Ja.
Sort of home
when you see the mountains ...
Aber es ist trotzdem nicht dasselbe.
Doch, wenn ich ganz oben
Erde in die Hand nehme,
dann riecht das genau gleich
wie in Tibet.
Aber hier unten ist es anders.
Ganz oben
- Ja, genau.
Merci vielmals.
* Gemächliche Musik *
(Hier im Tent Village
spannen alle ein wenig aus.)
(Drüben im Hostel
laufen die Vorbereitungen für den
amerikanischen Nationalfeiertag.)
(Und auch die Waschmaschine
dreht sich nonstop.)
(Rosalie und ihre Crew müssen Berge
von Bettwäsche bewältigen.)
(Hochbetrieb
herrscht auch an der Rezeption.)
(Eine Reisegruppe von 28 Australiern
ist soeben angekommen.)
(Die Jungfrau im Abendlicht -
als Kulisse des Tent Village.)
* Stimmengewirr *
(Es ist Happy Hour, und die Stimmung
wird immer ausgelassener.)
* Rockmusik *
(Ich mache mich
an der Bar nützlich.)
(Und drüben im Pool sehe ich
den Amerikaner von heute Morgen.)
Wieso bist du ausgerechnet
hierher gekommen?
Weil es am billigsten ist.
Es ist einfach sehr günstig,
und die Umgebung ist sehr schön.
Ich habe beschlossen,
drei Tage länger hierzubleiben.
Hier ist es sehr hübsch,
auch die Leute sind sehr hübsch.
And ...
Also diese Leute hier?
Ja, die Girls.
Es ist einfach cool.
Hier hat man alles, was man braucht.
(Am Abend vorne beim Balmers.)
* Glockenbimmeln *
(Schweizer Folklore zum
amerikanischen Nationalfeiertag -
ein Bild für die Götter.)
(Die Kühe hat der Patron
des Hostels, Erich Balmer,
nicht organisiert.)
(Sie sind Teil der Tellfestspiele
und haben nichts
mit dem 4. Juli zu tun.)
Heute ist der Unabhängigkeitstag
der USA.
* Jubel *
Yeah!
Wer von euch kommt aus den USA?
Und woher kommst du?
London.
Es ist schön,
dass ihr alle hier seid.
Egal, woher ihr kommt.
# What so proudly we hailed
at the twilight's last gleaming?
# Whose broad stripes and bright
stars through the perilous fight ...
(Der 74-jährige Erich Balmer
ist total in seinem Element.)
# ...  and the home of the brave?
(Er hat hier schon viele Feste
gefeiert, das merkt man.)
Erich, für solche Momente wie eben
lebst du.
Das ist so.
Aus der Erfahrung von 50 Jahren
Jugendtourismus weiss ich:
Sie sind die besten Botschafter.
"Say you know a fun place,
cheap and chic?"
"Go to Balmers."
Andere Anbieter sind auch gut.
Du machst das nicht nur,
weil es funktioniert.
Du machst das auch,
weil du es gerne machst, nicht?
Ja, sicher. Stimmt.
Ich habe gesehen,
wie du es genossen hast.
Ja, stimmt.
Das ist richtig.
Wie viele haben dir zugetraut,
einen solchen Erfolg zu haben,
als du mit dieser Idee
zurück nach Matten kamst?
Da musst du jene fragen, die sagten:
"Dieser billige Backpacker
von Balmer."
Das waren v.a. Hoteliers.
Nichts gegen sie, aber ich
bin stolz, ein Herbergier zu sein.
Ich bin kein Hotelier,
kein Restaurateur und kein Wirt.
Nichts gegen sie.
The Balmer way is the different way.
We are different -
das merkte man auch heute, nicht?
Total, ja.
Viele Familienbetriebe
in der Region,
die gleichzeitig wie du
begonnen haben, gibt es nicht mehr
oder sie wurden von
ausländischen Investoren aufgekauft.
Was macht das mit dir?
- Das tut mir sehr weh.
Kürzlich hatten wir so ein Beispiel,
100 m nebenan -
es tut mir leid, ich möchte es
eigentlich nicht wiederholen.
Es hätte nie passieren dürfen,
dass bei uns in der Kernzone,
wo wir sind ...
Eine indische Gruppe
hat ein Hotel übernommen.
Ein paar Hunderttausend Franken
gaben den Ausschlag.
Wir Einheimische
hatten einen Vorschlag gemacht.
Wir haben auch den Gemeinderat
um Hilfe gebeten.
Ich bin überzeugt,
dass es gut gekommen wäre.
Leider klappte es nicht.
Die Banken helfen uns nicht -
das ist himmeltraurig.
Wir haben keine Lobby.
Wenn das so weitergeht ...
Schon jetzt ist jedes fünfte Hotel
zwischen dem Thuner- und Brienzersee
indisch, chinesisch
oder südkoreanisch.
Und was passiert?
Dann kommen sie
mit eigenen Charterflügen -
z.B. aus China -
in die eigenen Hotels,
bringen ihr eigenes Essen mit
und bestimmen noch,
wo sie rauf dürfen und wo nicht.
Und dann
setzen sie auch noch den Preis fest.
Das finde ich himmeltraurig.
Das beschäftigt mich sehr.
(Sorgen wie Erich macht sich hier
heute Abend sonst niemand.)
(Ab 22 Uhr geht die Party im Klub
im Keller des Balmers weiter.)
* Partymusik *
(Und hier kommt auch
unser Gast aus Amerika
seinem Ziel langsam etwas näher.)
(Auch die Balmers-Crew
mischt sich unters Volk.)
(Gefeiert wird
bis in den Morgen hinein,
aber für mich
ist irgendwann Feierabend.)
* Gemächliche Musik *
(Am dritten Morgen
finde ich mich im Balmers-Labyrinth
schon alleine zurecht.)
(Die Häuser sind alt und nicht
praktisch für einen Hostel-Betrieb.)
(Dank des guten Rufs könne man
im Wettbewerb noch mithalten.)
(Was im Falle einer Renovierung
sein wird, weiss niemand so genau.)
Wir haben noch Lost-and-Found-Sachen
in den Zimmern gefunden.
Super.
Musst du noch ein Foto machen?
- Merci. Ja, genau.
Heute grosser Abreisetag?
- Eigentlich schon.
Aber sie checken später aus,
weil gestern 4. Juli war.
Morgen, Max.
(Max taucht auf,
und für einen Moment fühlt es sich
eher wie eine Familie an
als ein Arbeitsort, wo man laufend
Backpacker ein- und auscheckt.)
Thank you.
Hallo, wie geht's?
Gut, ich habe wieder einen Pass.
- No, really?
Nice!
War es schwierig?
Nein, sie waren sehr nett.
Es ist jetzt gut,
und jetzt kann ich weiter.
Das ist in dem Fall ein Happy End.
Absolut, allerdings.
Thank you so much, girls.
Alles Gute,
und pass auf deinen Pass auf!
Jawohl, immer.
(Nach dem Auschecken
ist vor dem Einchecken.)
(Jedes Bett
muss frisch angezogen werden.)
(Ich helfe Rosalie
nochmals beim Bettenmachen.)
(Oder sie mir.)
Nicht perfekt, aber ...
Wohin gehst du in die Ferien?
- Normalerweise nach Griechenland.
Und was machst du in Griechenland?
Zwei Wochen, ja.
- Zwei Wochen ...
... relaxen.
- Im Liegestuhl?
Und ich höre dann nichts.
Niemand, der etwas von Rosalie will?
Nichts.
- Keine Wäsche.
Nichts, nichts, nichts.
Kannst du zwei Wochen nichts tun?
- Doch, doch. Ich brauche das.
Super.
Ja, das glaube ich.
Du hast jeden Tag
11, 12 Std. gearbeitet? - Ja.
Rollen, rollen, rollen.
- Jetzt ist gut, ja.
Dorje macht auch gute Rouladen.
Das ist gut. - Zufrieden?
Ja, das ist super.
Den Rouladentest bestanden?
- Ja, ich bin zufrieden.
Sicher?
- Ja.
Bist du zufrieden?
- Ja, aber damit nicht.
Weisst du, ihr macht das alles
mit viel Kopf und Liebe.
Und jetzt so?
- Ja.
So.
- Ja?
Wie lange muss ich bei dir arbeiten,
um perfekt zu werden?
Einen Monat.
Ungefähr. - Mindestens.
- Ja, mindestens.
Hei, also jetzt ...
- Das ist super, ja.
Danke für drei Tage Einführung.
- Merci vielmals.
Rosalie, danke vielmals.
Ich danke dir.
Dank dir werde ich künftig
die Betten schöner anziehen.
Ich werde dich nie vergessen.
- Roulade, Roulade, Roulade.
Was hat Rosalie gesagt?
"Roulade, Roulade, Roulade."
Yes!
(Aber erst muss ich noch
ein anderes Abenteuer überstehen.)
(Susan geht Gleitschirm fliegen
und nimmt mich mit.)
(Ich soll ihn noch selber erleben,
den Adrenalinkick,
der die ganze Welt hierherzieht.)
* Bedächtige Musik *
(Mein Deltaseglerpilot
heisst Peter.)
(Susan ist schon startbereit.)
So cool!
Hammer, dass du mitmachst!
Du hast gesagt, wer bei euch
arbeiten will, müsse das machen.
Das stimmt.
- Ich freue mich.
Super Einsatz.
- Einen ganz guten Flug!
Cool, dass du uns besucht hast.
- Danke vielmals.
Wir sehen uns
hoffentlich nochmals dort oben.
Guten Flug! - Bis später,
viel Spass, geniesse es!
Cool, voila. Let's go!
(Peter) Voila.
(Susan) Juhu!
Wow!
Schön aufrecht hinstehen.
Gehen wir?
- Ja.
Drei, zwei, eins ...
- Oh my God!
Gemütlich laufen,
etwas schneller, etwas schneller -
und schon fliegen wir.
Du kannst rechts loslassen.
- Ja.
Das Ding runterschiessen.
Schön ruhig draufstehen,
und jetzt richtig durchdrücken.
Wow!
Ist es bequem?
- Yeah! Juhu!
(Was kann man dazu noch sagen?
Vielleicht awesome oder great?)
(Und auf einmal versteht man,
was Hunderttausende junge Menschen
hierherzieht.)
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Philipp Schlatter - 2019